so i'm curious you haven't directed a
feature since oz the great and powerful
i'm curious how close did you come to
directing something else before this and
after odds i didn't come close to direct
anything after that i needed time away
after that to uh
get hungry again um learn about
filmmaking take in some lessons
do some gardening
avocados absolutely among other things
yeah exactly um you have the ability
with this film to
there's a lot more modern vfx the tools
you had to make this film are so
different than the the spider-man movies
you made what technology did you have
access to on this film that you wish you
had access to when you were making the
spider-man films we had to make a lot of
the tools to make the tools back in the
day of spider-man john dykstra in fact
said to me sam the tools don't exist to
do what we're talking about making a cgi
spider-man but if we start now we can
develop the technologies so that they'll
be ready for us when we need them in a
year and a half and i went that's the
coolest thing i ever heard in my life
let's do that and we did and the
technologies were there for us so
certainly that has become much easier
now there's whole companies that are set
up to make cgi characters they've got
great new programs in place the
pipelines are laid
but the so the newest tools i think
technologically that helped me were
actually the telecommunication tools
zoom for instance to be able to
speak to a hundred different crew
members around the world at the same
time to share a storyboard i could have
my storyboard artist put up a storyboard
to explain something to us or
i could have the art department bring up
a design so that we could look at it
with the director of photography and
talk about how we'd light it or i could
at this on the same call have
my editor show a clip of a scene that
was partially edited so we could really
understand where this insert would go
between which two shots that tool
is incredibly uh helpful and a great new
advance in movie making uh i know this
movie has cameos we don't have to get
into the the specifics but i am curious
was there any
cameo or easter egg that you put in
specifically to amuse you
no not not really this was all done
to titillate the fans and surprise them
to make them gasp to give them
not exactly what they expected but
something that they would love
i'm obsessed with the editing process
because it's ultimately where it all
comes together i know that marvel has a
very hands-on approach to the editing
process it's
it's a different process than perhaps
you've done in the past and i'm just
curious what was that relationship like
and
you know that back and forth working
with them they were very supportive of
myself and my editors
bob marowski and tia nolan
driving the driving the train they had
their notes they had their suggestions
and they were they were really good
because they're a company that
primarily just looks out for the
integrity of their characters so the
notes really come from a great place
it's not about making more money for the
studio it's about
no this is what doctor strange would say
no this is what happened in the last
avengers movie and this is contrary to
that we have to be on the same page so
their notes come from a really great fan
fan place uh i know that this movie is
definitely gonna have deleted scenes um
are there can you tease for fans even
though we haven't seen the movie yet um
like how many deleted scenes you might
want to release down the road i'm trying
to remember what marvel is including in
the deleted scenes
it's really going to be their decision
but
i know that there are at least two or
three deleted scenes that will be
included i don't know the full extent of
them though i know the movie is like two
hours five minutes 210 i don't know the
exact thing did you have a much longer
cut that you brought to that like i'm
always curious about first cuts and you
know that kind of stuff well the first
cut was i actually don't remember the
length of it it was probably like two
hours and 40 minutes
and it slowly came down
even though we did the reshoots
we took out material even though the
reshoots went in so
it slowly got down to about two hours
and
five minutes is the total totally um
listen i wish i had more time i'm
already out i'm just gonna say i cannot
wait to see the movie
you